well I just saw it 45 minutes ago you  posted you chopped your hair when did  you do this this morning that's ring we  do what we do each other to each other's  hair cuts are you guys going to be  roaming the convention floor in disguise  I can't disclose that information yeah I  want to know exactly what you're wearing  so that I can I you exactly yeah well  were you as well yeah that's what I'm  gonna wear what we're about to go into  Hall H what are we going to see today I  haven't seen it yet so I'm gonna be that  with you the first time seeing it Dane's  one of it so yeah I saw it for the first  time last night and I left really  excited yeah well there's like some  undisclosed roles in here we got Rihanna  coming in what was it like working with  her it was great he's meeting people